what up what up what up everyone that's
Gary Vee this is pod sessions number 9 I
have three phenomenal guests I'm gonna
allow them to introduce themselves in a
minute who they are where they're from
what they do and then we'll go through
the show we haven't done one of these in
a while oh what's fun about this is
maybe unlike any other pod sessions I've
already spent time with all three
individuals so it makes it a little
cozier it's a little warmer I'll try to
do my best to not forget any of the
context or make sure it gets thrown in
here but these are three people that I
have a lot of respect for for different
reasons and so I'm excited about this
show so let's start with the lovely lady
to the left I mean we'll go around who
are you what do you do where you from
what's your scene
my name is Lexy Panterra and I'm a
singer actress entertainer dancer and I
own my own company's clothing line
twerkout class and yeah that's me I'm
from El Gordo la in Sactown twerkout
class work out so how so real quick
before we go further you live in LA now
yep we're in New York love New York real
quick which city do you like better New
York or LA tell the truth don't [ __ ]
I love living in LA hundred percent
because we shine everything that I mean
you can get the ocean like I think it's
just I love ocean here I don't think
I've really been to an ocean around you
anywhere near New York we need to change
that but I like the energy here so when
I come here I get like a huge amp of
energy and then I go to LA like running
[ __ ] okay I gotta understand how often
you head to New York I have a couple
months I think I try to come back I'm
glad you're back
oh me too well they can do a little mini
my man hey what's up my name is David
Ben David founder creative director and
CEO of sprayground
Sprague on his bags luggage is a whole
world of chaos for the creative outcasts
over the world I love that so far
everybody's listening I want to just
jump in here as well like sprayground
you know when I think about brands that
are doing it right especially in apparel
or whatever that genres called not food
you know like bags or luggage or
sneakers or t-shirts things that nature
very few brands I think have have
navigated culture the the attention of
the consumer better than sprayground
over the last decade and so when we got
to meet I really enjoyed that and I'm
excited you're here
Thank You Brad you gotta my man yo Nigel
Sylvester here professional bike rider
rational dreamer doesn't make [ __ ]
happen bro man I I do feel you but for
the for the percentage the audience
thing is really cool in my opinion like
like when you say that what do you mean
Robbie bicycles on a professional level
concentrator so so for me it's always
been about I'm creating videos or
shooting dope photos and just share my
story being a kid from Queens New York
and going about my sport in a very
unconventional way so let's put it down
I'm gonna actually piggyback off this I
want to go back the other way around I
want to go into comic book number one
the origin story like cool I know where
you're from what you do now let's go a
hair deeper like paint the picture for
the audience this is also I know we're
recording it but there's also audio like
where were you born
how did it happen like what's your story
like parents like give me some real
[ __ ] like nothing gnarly
oh oh one stuff not for sure so
important cleans born in Queens
first-generation to immigrant parents
both my parents from Rhode Island kagune
de where the u.s. invaded again [ __ ]
believe like BMX which wasn't even a
thought there you know I mean or
something about that BMX is not a
thought in Queens either which is why
I'm for X Games and ESPN and things that
way to it so you're growing up here
you're means you're watching ESPN you
see they're flipping off of like on the
bike show that that's fresh I was like a
super dope seeing dudes like Dave Meyer
and Matt Hoffman Ryan Ike was seeing
those dudes like ride contests and
chiliad and like there we kinda like
these BMX like superheroes and I was
like man that looks super cool I want to
do that didn't really have those
facilities out in Queens wet the mix
ooh-wee like whatever we had so grinding
a Ledge or handrails there so but if we
could what I'm really interested in this
[ __ ] so middle you see it do you run to
your mom and say can you buy me a bike
no we have to find a bike there's
certain ways to find bikes like steel
first bike now my first buddy I know you
know the bikes that I like throw out my
like Chama if I found bikes I would try
tricks like would jump off her curves
would make like a little border when you
have a crew like you know what's
interesting to me about we like how long
how old are you now I'm 31
right and this is when you were how old
I was a kid man six six seven years old
like a so you know 25 years ago I grew
up in this area like being in Queens and
rolling up on your homies in and being
like yo let's BMX yeah versus video
games or basketball or all the other
things was that did you have a crew or
people into it or was it like just one
or two of you see the thing about of
those like growing up in Queens everyone
would ride bikes so what they go from
the house to the park to go play
basketball or from your crib to your
friend's life to go play video games it
was a mode of transportation and in
having a dope bike was important so
having like a GT with the mags or a dyno
with their mags in it that was something
important of course you know I mean like
you gotta have a fresh bike so that
would like easily translate from well K
you have a dope bike and now they can
you pop a wheelie
oh how long can you pop a wheelie for Oh
keep jumping off this curb and it's like
for me I just kept building and building
I became addicted to the feeling of
landing tricks I was I want to live
bigger tricks I want to like go in grind
longer Pappa wheelie longer and I just
took that and just kept running with it
and as I would ride through the
neighborhood I would meet different kids
who rode bikes and whatnot anyway the
best players could figure each other out
the a crew small this like this was like
the Alto all these kids are riding bikes
and everybody's got their little crew
the best rider in each crew eventually
there's a point where those wanted to
come together no different than
basketball by the weight
entrepreneurship the other kids that
knew how to sell baseball cards
hey my homies
it's all the same [ __ ] yo games like you
know how many times you want to be your
boy and Matt and I ain't nothing you got
to find somebody else I can play of
course in like you would share that
information and once I start to find out
about places like Union Square I was
like okay I gotta leave Queens and go to
the city because that's what the best
riders were select you were saying
everyone would like go out to like the
spot and just saying Queens you're not
going there to get clowned on now like
I'm riding from my crib to Jamaica
station and then jump on the E train all
the way so like 14 and then right across
the Union Square they said it was a
whole journey every single day to get to
the city to hang out with the best
riders like unless if you realized that
you were really really good all right
away like that happens right no no no I
mean this is not like a silicon you
don't need to be bash for like okay now
you go to the major leagues and you're
in Union Square that's when you know all
these steps in life you sometimes
realize oh okay
I'm not gonna be in the NBA oh okay I'm
not gonna be an eSports star or oh okay
I'm not gonna be an entrepreneur that
makes ten billion dollars there's a
moment or the reverse which is like wait
a minute if that dudes the best hmm I'm
like that
that's a very important moment for
everybody in their life I'm just curious
night it was very special at that craft
of writing I'm curious like when did you
say oh [ __ ]
I'm real good when I feel like it was to
happen to different points the first
point wasn't realizing a cool I need to
get out of my neighborhood because like
the like the I feel for like when you
put yourself around other people I was
super good like super amazing I won't
they do it helps you raise the bar so I
thought needed to be around weight
better riders to help me raise like
miles that happened then and then I was
like got on that scene I started to see
the tricks I was doing um I was like
okay cool like now it's now like now
understand like I'm gonna admit I'm in a
good position and if I continue to grind
it super hard and like be true to myself
which is a very very important thing as
well being true to yourself um that's
not real I take it collects like
something's really hate it I can like
bubble up I got some more stuff you in a
minute how are you born where no special
everywhere I go in the world that was
bumping
makes sense really
that makes sense I have a partner he's
uh he owns a house and a zoo there I was
there and then just like a giraffe and
zebra zoo yeah it's like a thousand
animals Tigers right so you want to go
there for over contact two loggers and
there's only six like this I don't even
I don't even know what oh that's a half
lion half tiger there is another way oh
by the way soon there's gonna be like
lying in the [ __ ] the science oh we're
about to become so crazy out here
look you think like fake lips and fake
asses are crazy going to be flying and
half-human soon
the robots are coming by the way on a
serious note cloning is closed
like just to get it real weird and your
real quick and by the way I'm interested
well what's the point I want to live
forever the point is like I'm gonna make
another me and be like if I get hit by
tree other means gives you [ __ ]
dominating but you're not there honestly
it's so [ __ ] it's like internet right
I'm old enough you some there's some
youngsters in here you actually don't
know life pre-internet let me tell you
something you didn't know the internet
was gonna be a thing like you didn't
know how insane it was gonna be you
didn't know how I was gonna change it
like I don't know you're probably right
but I don't know I have no idea what a
clone me and a me interact like what's
that gonna be like I just think it's
gonna be amazing
hopefully I hope so the fact that I
could be here and give a keynote right
now in Dubai oh [ __ ] you ready to go
origin story let's do it
born where I was born in the Bronx my
family uh my parents split up early was
that a like a tub I think about looking
looking back it was awesome sure cuz I
don't want to be like that guy yeah even
though he's is a nice guy in theory yeah
for like I want to be like that and
that's what keeps me going
it makes me hungry for blood again I
understand it early yes so then moved to
move to Florida I guess I just got stuck
in one part of Florida Hollywood Florida
okay nice little neighborhood there and
I was always put in front of a TV i
watch movie since I was young and
looking back also that's probably a good
thing cuz like it helped fuel my
creativity not that I'm saying you
should you know put your kids in front
of TV and movies but I saw movies for
some reason it this is interesting you
said this this gives me a chance to get
off something I'm passionate about all
the current parents in the world
[ __ ] on iPads and iPhones believe me
your kids this that I'm completely the
other way oh really yeah
Lex I'm like what no I was super
creative when I was young and it's like
imaginative and you know I mean me too
and what have you but here's what I'm
saying what world do you think our kids
are gonna be living in like technology
doesn't go backwards like everybody
demonizes [ __ ] without realizing all the
benefits like like it's just so
interesting like when I hear that like
think about this I just asked you about
your origin story within the first two
minutes you talked about consuming
content in video form from a device like
you know I just think that people
underestimate [ __ ] so anyway keep going
yeah did that went to uh went to a
little private school of twenty six kids
and he always used to draw on the board
like crazy images and then and then and
then the teacher would come in and he
would make sure that I would erase the
board it was a little pornographic yeah
you know like 12 years old drawing this
crazy scenes on the board and all the
kids were loving it yes and they wanted
me to do it before class started and do
you the attention huh did you love the
attention
yeck that my art was getting like people
going oh is awesome like I do that but
it got me suspended twice okay that's
fine and
it was good for the origin story yeah
and I didn't really wanted to pursue
something in creativity I wanted to do
something for many of my time I wanted
to go to the military I don't know why I
liked I liked how the military designed
their things like a bullet
you know it's designed through science
it has to be aerodynamic an f-16 fighter
jet like that thing it just excites me
you know I like the action movies maybe
that's why interesting this is all going
so my mom pushed me to go to art school
so I went to the School of Visual Arts
here and and after I graduated I pursued
a career of creativity and it's been
what happened first in regards to your
career what was the first thing you did
oh I just jumped in and decided to do my
own thing I really want to work for
anybody and so what did you make they
wouldn't understand me I actually
applied to a hundred jobs no one took me
and I just started was just my own thing
financing uh with the with the bags
right to the backs pretty much yeah no
[ __ ] I didn't know that it was I I did I
didn't know how to make a bag I had to
go to China a few times figure that out
well how long ago was this this was I
started eight years ago but probably
like a year and change of just figuring
[ __ ] out so like almost nine ten years
ago yeah but our our real official 2020
would be our ten-year anniversary
that's exciting a little bit let's see I
grew up in Sacramento in LA split up
home wanted to be a singer my entire
existence of life and a dancer
everything came natural kind of I moved
to LA when I was 16 how to get out of
the hood because my dad was like you
can't do anything here so I went to LA
got into acting and stuff my whole
family does it somebody my whole
family's in like car racing and and what
is it called my dad did stunt work and
all that stuff but I was never heavily
into the business like I literally
probably the past two years I've
actually learned the most about the
music industry sure so that's that just
one word you said yeah I've always so
I've always recorded I mean I was in a
girl group when I was younger yeah let's
talk about that for a minute I was like
17
it was Motel XL someone found me at
I'm dance studio and they're like can
you sing you're like yeah actually I can
so you started recording like like
literally like yeah looks amazing [ __ ]
yeah I was like five pretty cool girls
and we all sang and we all like I opened
up for Keith Sweat back in the day
that's like like did you guys go to like
malls and perform and [ __ ] no we didn't
get that far
the group split up oh god I'd be on
state out of that not just but I've
always I mean I then I went solo started
doing an album I got some stuff on
Entourage and the radio my dad supported
my whole career when I watch he helped
me he took me 100% like the biggest fan
I have after that you know I went on my
own more and started learning more about
the business and started doing a couple
movies and stuff here and there but then
the twerkout class started and just
popped off my whole career this was
about five years almost five years ago
it's almost an anniversary for us to to
work out freestyle videos on insta Tube
online how much was a benign oriented
Ohno vine novo no I was about it was
gently Facebook YouTube and then I went
to Instagram so I started doing my
classes yes first came to classes then
came to YouTube videos they went viral
then I was like okay it was making me
money I was like cool so I got really
addicted to I'm like y'all it's making a
bunch of money whatever but I wasn't
really made money because that people
would see the tork how class and sign up
for the class or brands were coming to
you and wanted to give you money to do
some photos Emily only it was regen only
people coming in to take the class
understood yeah add some celebrity
friends at the time that your minute
took it so they loved it so
automatically they're like oh cool post
about it and that's how it grew and then
I kept up with YouTube and then I was
like wait like my passion is music like
so why am I not when did that I want to
say three years so again so that's
always done it unless they're not full
understand five years ago the twerk
thing blows up the studio the classes
the things of that nature two years into
it even though you're making a ton of
money like oh [ __ ] wait a minute
this thing is taking me away from my
true passion let me refocus or like like
really really focus on music yeah
yeah the past year and a half has been
really just music music music music I
started doing like I don't know like
rapping [ __ ] for it to work out videos
because I knew I could monetize my my
songs and stuff so I was like okay let's
just make this for that but that wasn't
the type of music I wanted to do so I
kind of did that but then I moved along
I'm like listen I need to just focus
strictly on music and that's my [ __ ]
that's where I'm at alright let's go
back around starting with you Lex okay
this is the part where I want to know
what you were currently obsessed with
right now yeah and before you answer
this I don't mean like some generic
ideology
I mean you bought a new toothbrush
that's so fresh or you found some show
on Netflix that you can't stop watching
or some sort of prot like something very
intriguing in your actual life we're
like no cameras on like like what in
your life are you currently obsessed
with like a new person a new gadget a
new app a new song a new food a new
restaurant
definitely a song 24/7 okay so trippin
on you bye boo LM a yes she's saying the
booth ah yes literally every single day
I'm in listening to that song hard 24/7
so I think that's what it'll it's always
music I think addicted to music yes love
it yeah it's my own craft coming up with
something new like now I'm um I'm making
music because right now I could only get
you're making music yeah I can only get
the fan through touch and see yes now I
want to add another sense to it so now
you use do you sing were you seriously
making it yeah I write it a sing it you
sing it a little bit it's [ __ ]
amazing yes right here
how bad our music is i will market the
[ __ ] out of em mungus and hungry but I
don't like I don't like much things out
of like you know like you keep [ __ ]
narrow like what you said about other
consumer stuff it doesn't really excite
me I'd like to share planes though I
like reading about Boeing and Airbus I
like flying huh it's awesome it's cool
so the song is so good yes I do because
I don't watch TV but I binge that thing
like two days like that's not serious it
was nice I'm in such a coma right now I
usually I don't jump in here but I just
want everybody know on the record the
Jets destroying the [ __ ] out of the
Lions on Monday night it has me I'm Full
Tilt I've barely been productive I can't
stop thinking about Sunday I want to
destroy the Dolphins Sam Donald's my guy
Jamaal at like I'm such in a coma right
now I'm literally in a bubble of New
York jetsam I'm barely concentrating I
got all sort of [ __ ] up like I'm barely
listening to you guys I'm just like I'm
already think about like if we can stop
the run and [ __ ] ryan tannenhill like
I'm already like I'm literally living a
parallel life while I'm living my
regular life because I love them so much
and the optimism behind our new
quarterback huge mm-hmm I have a collab
with the NFL should work on the Jets
come should design it done
sails for days Wow what's going on with
you in social media
I love weird me go ahead talk to me
about it telling me about it as a human
like what you [ __ ] with huh and and then
how you think about it for your business
or ambitions or aspirations I'm in as a
human on some real systems on the catch
myself like I'm spending way too much
time in what and just like scrolling
through Instagram
how much do you live in DM it's a form
of communication message it is um all
their real-life relationships I'm
talking to fans like I love to connect
with the people so I'll just go through
like the nuts like it's like the second
level idioms are your friends yeah and
they go crazy they love it yeah I can't
believe I'm it's awesome yeah you got
like honestly all my girlfriend's like
I'm just like sorry
like that's a whole different dynamic
it's crazy I love it and then also like
on business I mean like it's helped me
propel my career by the way you're
listening right now if you've not seen
some of Nigel's videos on YouTube they
are so incredible like d-roc was giddy
when we got connected he's like do you
even understand I'm like no I don't
consume anything but the Jets he's like
you gotta watch it I was like wow and
then when you saw showed me the preview
I actually sat watch that amazing such a
talent man thank you very very
impressive good night I'm really cool I
truly enjoy the process of thinking
about certain scenes and accustomed to
life like that process yes is incredible
so what what do you use use Instagram
Instagram Twitter Facebook YouTube no
snap I don't using that what do you do
with Facebook repost everything and I'm
doing understo oh did you use snap 24 36
48 months ago no got it
what about you social social Facebook
more for the International yes yep
international distribution and this is
now under the sprayground brand not you
as a person yeah I understood sometimes
I put too much attention into
sprayground yeah I mean that's like the
bread and butter yeah so my own of my
own Instagram gets a little bit
neglected yeah that's fine
yeah oh man have you thought about wait
a minute
I'm gonna start doing other creative
things like music and other things I may
want to think about that has lost your
mind yeah this anymore except then
manpower on it I get it but it's good to
talk to the fans and then when I started
do pop ups in like undisclosed locations
yes so it's cool afternoon like all my
thanks so much for answering my DM
they'll even like snap that and post it
that like that like post of course or
like respondents imagine when you're a
kid whoever your hero was reply like
when I think about when I think about I
tune my favorite Jets player if in 1988
my PMDD altoon and he said yo I would
have been I'd have been in coma for a
year let alone a day like you know I get
it it makes a ton of sense so for you
personally as a human do you use
anything like you know I use Instagram
for anything else just for me no it's
just in Sigma no Twitter no you could
see anything on YouTube mmm like you
watch some videos that's what's amazing
now you do these look like that you
could see anybody listening right I like
literally type into anything it's there
yeah like eating Hornets yep it's there
I think I'm on everything pretty much as
a human what do you use the most
Instagram Instagram anything else on my
phone probably Twitter yep anything else
I mean my YouTube and Facebook are
really big but that's more business see
yeah yeah I really did you ever I snap a
little bit yep did you snap more that
did you used to snap way more yeah I use
just that way more yep I mean seriously
I might have been not in the in the
camera face to face as much I've noticed
you've gone the other way
you're like socially commentating maybe
okay yeah I've noticed that change Reese
I just told her about funny you said
that I literally had a pretty famous
comedian in here just before we did this
and I was telling him one of the things
that I think he could do that's really
cool is I think people should take it
everybody's to their face right it's all
us I think the way you see the world is
like a big white space I think like an
Instagram account or
get really fresh if every post was you
talking over what you're looking at that
makes sense
I think so you a personality right yeah
or or you know my big thing is that I
think people getting way too precious
with their posts like the likes and the
feedback have crippled people and like
everyone's looking for the perfect shot
the right angle everyone's gotten real
fancy yeah and I think one of the ways
to break fancy is to go the other way
because your point to get a stop sign
and you might tell a story about when
you drove past a stop sign and [ __ ]
got into a car accident like whatever it
may be like I think that the world is a
canvas of creativity that people can be
using but they're so focused on
themselves that they're missing out on
all the context question for you like
what like what platforms are you using
what's a human person on a human level
nothing okay why not well are you
because I didn't text like as a human I
like put like on my jets threat like I'm
a very one-dimensional human meaning I
literally care about my friends and
family right and the New York Jets yeah
like I'm so wired in it to me I'm gonna
buy you you're just you know you're
gonna sing the national anthem but yes I
will right now but you're gonna be
oldest [ __ ] I need
thirty years has been a crazy so you can
[ __ ] up your voice it's done okay so
it's really interesting I so here's
what's different about me
definitely than you and most of the
listeners and a lot of people in the
room I was an adult when social came mmm
so like you know this I've so much pride
in the book I wrote crush it like if you
read that now what I wrote about social
media in 2008 like I was right so from
day one in my 30s as a wine store owner
I use social for business
I wasn't a human on social like I wasn't
a kid that grew up with social like it
didn't exist like AOL Instant Messenger
didn't exist for me I was already grown
so like you know you know so like that
so like for me social the internet it's
always been business it's always been
business like and so for me I popped
very early and very quick on Twitter and
YouTube in 2006 so it's been now twelve
full years of me navigating from a
business standpoint so I've never been
removed from the business part of social
the way I was never removed from wine
like when I drink wine today for the
first time in my entire life I drink
wine today
and kind of enjoy it as wine not as
business because I grew up in the
business of it like right like for
example for you when you listen to music
you're actually analyzing things that I
don't I just [ __ ] music - it's so
upsetting look I see products
my intuition based on the way you're
talking you're looking at things from a
different lens than I I'm like so so I
always you know that's right from a
design standpoint from a engineering
step which so for me I don't use social
as normal now as a business person I'm
I'm like on Full Tilt I'm everything
podcasts LinkedIn YouTube medium Korra
face but like we are a full pledge Media
[ __ ] Empire so I'm thinking about
written word audio video like you know
it's like it's my life so and not only
my life it's up my best
this so it's pretty deep in that way but
do you enjoy it still I want you I to me
there's nothing more exciting than in
the process I don't like the stuff that
the process gives you my great advantage
is I don't like the stuff that the
process gives you so that's my absolute
advantage like I don't want the cars or
the houses or I just want to be good at
my craft it feels good you know I love
that I think I connect with you on that
quite a bit I took that away from when
we met like six months ago what have you
I was like oh [ __ ] I understand him he
wants to be great at his craft and I
think everybody does but there's some
people that actually only want to be
great at their craft for me I only want
to be great at my craft which means I'm
always in the process of my craft which
means I get to play forever
which means I'm fulfilled I'm quite good
what do you think about cuz growing up
I've just I've loved to do so many
things and I don't like to do just one
and I think that's why well I guess I've
been doing it like the music and the
tour know my whole everything a lot of
[ __ ] my whole life right acting but like
acting yeah but how do you I mean do you
think that it's a strike one
I think it's a strength I think people
[ __ ] on it and say you have to follow
people yeah of course they do people
that aren't artists oh yeah people might
Allison I can only do one counted it's
not that it's people it's not that it's
people like my big thing is like people
always come to me like Gary Vee you look
literally in the [ __ ] Street cuz I
think it all went down you'll guarantee
real quick like you said in a video last
week on Instagram blah blah said no I'm
like well what's your homie Jerome up to
not much
I'm like well then think about who's
giving the [ __ ] advice if a straight
man will say oh Lord focusing on this is
and if you look at that and if you look
at them and they're a lawyer or a
manager that makes sense
yeah they don't like I can't be that
first like I'm eight hundred thousand
[ __ ] things going on you know why I
will suffocate if I don't my core thing
vaynermedia would not be successful if I
didn't have Gary Vee if I didn't have
you know like the Green Street if I
didn't have Vayner sports if I didn't
have Wine Library if I didn't have the
case was collaboration like if I don't
have a [ __ ] million things going on
if I focus on one thing that [ __ ]
thing is dead
I've built a two hundred million dollar
company from scratch because I've been
doing all this other side hustle that's
not that's the answer I like other
people that artistic whether their
business artistic or as artistic as
every right they understand everybody
here understood that they've got to get
their nut off in different ways but
somebody who's not creative amen
right base alright you know they show
you the reason you can like you need to
scratch other itches otherwise you get
suffocated keep on in life right no but
you should at least master something I
meet a lot of people that I want to be a
freaking mogul okay but were you gonna
start at first I want to do everything
they want to do everything it's a
problem to your point you just said two
things like if you were pitching it that
way that's exactly right because they
haven't said anything yet yeah I want to
be a mogul I want to do everything no no
you didn't say anything yet no but if
they're like brother everybody you know
what's so funny so many people want to
do creative things because they think
that's how they're gonna make money to
your point people do things for the
wrong reasons alright I agree you should
do something I mean if you're fortunate
up to some that you [ __ ] love it and
do it you're very interesting to me
because you don't look the part of the
normal BMX but and I think that that
means you [ __ ] loved it like like I'm
really kind of leaning into a new
version of myself on this like right now
I can't stop making content around going
to garage sales and thrift stores and
flipping
I can't stop and I have a lot of people
saying like yo you're hurting your brand
like why are you going into that like
who gives a [ __ ] if you bought something
for a dollar and sold it for eight Oh
Gary B and I'm like I don't give a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and bro on a very serious note in a
world where 98% of the people listening
here would love to make an extra ten
thousand dollars a year like I know how
easy it is if they just listen
everybody's trying to build the next
Instagram meanwhile I just tweeted this
some kid literally as you guys were
walking in here some kids like yo Gary
Vee you changed my life
I literally just bought this razor
scooter at Target on closeout for 70
bucks I took a picture of it this guy
took a gangster he's like I took a
picture of it in the score Oh Facebook
marketplace somebody bought it for 200 I
bought it for 70 drove two miles and
sold it for 200 your point I love you
for that to me when kids are like you
want me to build a neck sensor Ram y'all
I'm gonna build a neck snap yeah next
Boober I'm gonna be a mogul I'm gonna
like have you ever made any money like
right like to me the lemonade stand kid
the blow pop kid the burn the CD kid the
baseball card kid like like the kid eat
when I wake up at 4:30 and go to the
airport cuz I take a lot of 6:00 a.m.
flights and I drive by and see a bunch
of kids in line knowing they're buying
some limited-edition bag some in
addition sneaker some limited edition
something I look at them and I'm like
those are my people not when I go into
these big corporations and see the CMOS
that I love I love them but they're not
my people not because that doesn't mean
they're not good that means that they
were great at school that their degree
the process that they're great at foot
like that's just not me I'm great at
waking up at 3:30 not giving a [ __ ] what
anybody thinks standing in line during a
[ __ ] snowstorm getting my $80.00 pair
of something and selling it for [ __ ]
215 on stock X the next day that's me
and I'm gonna do that all the way to
[ __ ] winning six Super Bowls and
everybody's mouth that's what I'm gonna
do all right what are you gonna do
that's what I'm gonna do
Lex what are you gonna
but I'm sure so what are you go ahead
please
we were talking about it when we first
met about how like I was selling pokemon
cards lemonade stand
you should have kept those took them he
was like you're not allowed to sell me
that was such an important part of like
okay I can [ __ ] with our like that's
like my crazy I was like yes now who's
gonna pay for my lunch no I don't know
but yeah let's go around what are you
most excited about or trying to achieve
in the next 24 months go Nigel Wow
building my building the go brand that's
what I'm most excited about a filler has
a great potential
tell everybody what to go brandy so so
pretty much I do it video series called
go started off a couple years a few
years ago um just as as an idea that
didn't wait for someone to tell me yes
or no just when I did it it made it put
it on YouTube anyway viral um which was
incredible and sorry how many under now
five yeah we have five episodes now or
well over 50 million views like total
and how often do you do an episode we do
two episodes a year understand and it's
a great platform because I'm able to
have you seen him you're gonna stretch I
go I can't wait for you to see it but
I'm able to bring my entire world like
every piece of it from like me fry ride
my bicycle to travel to style and
fashion so the people I interact with
all in this in this one video so you
want to keep building or continue to
build that and no so what's the
aspiration you know do you you know
obviously brands want to get into raid
there's money there of course there's
you could literally I don't know maybe
you can open theaters like I don't know
like like have you thought about the
business around it or you still trying
to know so so like beyond just like the
video series in itself there's that
there's a whole merch program not
another now so like bring it in like the
idea okay I'm up I'm in Tokyo and I get
inspired by a design how can I now go
and recreate that you know although or
give my rendition of that what that is
and in also doing a live events where
like I'm planning to do a go festival so
good for you and bringing it videos to
life you know the previous entire
lifestyle around oh based off of
inspired by this video series that I
started you know say my guy building
house the most important thing for me
right now my man I can't wait to watch
that that's great yeah
what about using for mattress 24 months
yeah I like I like to travel I like to
travel for business I like to travel
when there's multiple things to do like
flying to Italy meet a distributor do a
photo shoot go to the museum meet
someone to collaborate with do all that
I like doing that so like do more of it
and undisclosed locations like India you
know that's my next thing or like
Australia
hey I haven't broke that market yet I
think that that's a focus for us I'm
doing more runway I'm expanding the
brand there I like the whole and it's a
good idea and we have a lot of
interesting collaborations there with
that and then the music the music is fun
it's called money on the plane like
planes we go yeah so so that's gonna be
fun because to make but what's cool
about it the last video I shot there was
five levels on a plane there's a
meditation room there was a party room
there was room that had sharks swimming
in it
there was a massage room there was a
cannabis room so like taking these
visuals and really stimulating the
audience to like another level
I loved it legit where's that where's
that plane you may not yeah you gonna
buy tickets
[Applause]
I'm charging you for this
music music I want to release my EP I
want to tour it either open it for
someone song right now like that really
not a sign yeah like I was walking down
the street the other day walking down
the street like you know like people
love to yeah I heard I was super smiling
cheek to cheek like like that caught
some win right is my wind out there
shotgun two radio stations out there
it's a really catchy song younger kids
like it older people like it it's just
like a ultimate like what do you want to
get the p-side to like who when do you
want the project to launch I'm not
positive I mean hopefully within the
next couple months who's the producer
you want to work with the most I want to
work with the most anybody stand out I
mean or who's a producer you want to
work with anybody stand out where it's
not like that around a lot of producers
that I like they can reach out to me
there's some DJ's that I you know that
I'd like to collab with how does it work
we have you here
like you're something and you're just
like that I in the studio yeah I like to
listen to the beats I don't really like
the process of them creating the track
I'll go in there and automatically like
oh I have a melody boom let's do it and
then I just write to it it's like that
how often do you write whenever I'm in
the studio I don't ever write when I'm
not in the studio really no I don't like
writing like nasus man no no no I got to
be in there I have to hear a beat
sometimes I'm in my car and I'll hear a
song on the radio and I can trigger
sending them down a little and it
triggers something and then I'll be in
my notes and I have like two phones I'm
like trying to record while driving it's
really bad but like I'll write some full
songs doing that so funny one of my head
just went in 2008 when I first started
my speaking career there was a really
big-time speaker and he looked at me as
okay you know like I saw some video
online like really he's like he's so
we're like sitting we're both speaking I
think he's going up first I'm like an
hour late over in the green room he goes
how long did you work on your
presentation for today's speech and I
was like
I don't have a presentation and it was
super interesting and he was like and he
was like and it was interesting it
wasn't like I got scared or like thought
he wasn't like it was an interesting
conversation he's like I've worked for
three weeks on this presentation and he
was talking about his process and how he
does the slide and the keynote and this
and that and changing the word and like
practice I've never been like and I was
like wow and and then like I'm just like
I just to this day I'm just like go
onstage and wing it I'm like because
because for me my style is I'm gonna
talk about what I'm living this is the
current state of the internet media
culture like this is what it is I would
do it just as I'm doing this whether
it's one person or 80,000 but it's just
back to people's process that's so
interesting to me like I love what I'm
you people I'm like Wendy writes like
when I feel it or like this and that
like only in the studio like pretty
improv like that means you're like just
oh it's yeah I'll have ideas of constant
peace on the thought because I think
that's that how does how did that go
down if you sign me and my friend Jensen
were in the studio and then I think I
was talking about an ex-boyfriend hers
on there like someone I dated which is
yeah and then uh I don't he actually
came up piece I and turn it around part
yeah and then we just wrote the whole
zone around that pretty much it was
amazing
parting shots Nigel we're bouncing out
here you get to say anything you [ __ ]
watch the shots of Queens
go mode all day I said I loved it I said
oh praise the Lord and thank you shams
that's it you know who you know who has
Shem is know Hashem is the name it means
the name you know like the game is the
game yes he is the name powerful I love
that that's the creative I just happen
to creative source that's it I love that
thanks for being on Lex well che go by
my new single peace sign hallelujah say
that thanks guys for being on thank you
Gary you're the best see ya
[Music]